But accessibility considerations
won't be enough to reach all users,
you also need to consider localization.
To reach the most users,
your application should handle text,
audio files, numbers, currency and
graphics in ways appropriate to
the locales where your
application will be used.
This is actually pretty simple if you
use the Android resource framework
to separate the localized
aspects of your application
from the core Java functionality.
You can put most of the contents of
your apps UI into resource files,
whereas the behavior of the UI
is driven by your Java code.
For example, if users input
data that needs to formatted or
sorted differently depending on locale.
Then you would use Java to handle
the data programmatically.
But alternative strings or
layouts can live in the XML.